yeah yeah yeah yeah tick-tock let's go
photoshopping the boys and seeing if
they notice
this is such a good idea i can't believe
i've never done this
bro
mind if i post this on instagram
[Music]
chilling with the hunchback of notre
dame
that's so good bro just go for it i look
great thank you i trust my boy will make
me look good
oh i have to do this no one's ever going
to take a photo with me now first tick
tock to actually make me laugh a bit
yeah that's good i appreciate that okay
watch this this is kevin's ball if i
touch it it's gonna go mad it's gonna go
absolutely sick
[Laughter]
i'm touching it
i'm touching it no i like that poor
doggy like you could never like
that's impossible it can't be done
no
no the forbidden word
that's illegal the fbi will come
[Music]
oh my god
jacksepticeye
[Music]
why is this funny
[Music]
whoa
yes
oh that's amazing
i need to do this with edgar egger come
here
i forgot he's useless he can't do
anything i will never be able to
jump a rope with money
why did you stop
he wanted to do more he was look he did
it why did you just stop why did you
stop you dummy dumb you ruined them
then block his blind jab
count
physical recovery six weeks mental
recovery six months
beaten by a kitten priceless no bro i
hold on are you for real having fun
right now huh are you actually having
fun or not
but what is wrong with you
dude these guys like
let him play man look at this [ __ ]
it's funny because i can relate to this
running assassin's creed as a kid it's
fine i mean some parts run bad but i
mean when i'm on the horse it are you
for real having fun right now
are you actually having fun or not
he's also got a lower resolution in
window mode oh
oh blessed
as a gamer as a gamer right there hero
um
let the homie vibe
who's at the door
oh
[Laughter]
amazon could have been very awkward i'm
glad the neighbor laughed it out
no
don't don't
i thought it was a ratatouille thing
no i don't
i mean come on that that big boy will
last you at least a month you can feed
40 families for 40 days come on that
chunky boy
i've seen this
this is a classic
so she hit the audience attempt to
he can do it
oh
make her cut it out
someone stop her
makeup oh
yeah maybe we're back here a couple
kilometers
oh my god she hits the same person i
just realized it's the it's a woman here
it's the same person twice
make her stop
why is she doing this ah you know
usually what people do is they
go up and they apologize maybe give them
a signed glove or a golf ball i don't
know what the [ __ ] dude
thank you for choosing taco john's my
name is evan would you like to try the
two for four fish tacos tonight
hell no
all right you can go ahead and order one
of you ready all right can i get the two
for four fish tacos
no
no no no you had your chance i x you you
say no
hakko jongs
taco johns my favorite place
gotta get interested in juice better
special
no hell no
all right you can go ahead and order all
right all right
i'm getting paid to be polite so i'll
deal with it when you find a new v2 bird
but they won't show you their thighs
bruh [ __ ] cameo man i get it you want
to cash in on the meme that's a way to
do it but my man dude
he should be an actor it really nailed
that part oh gosh
what do you think the instructions for
this were hey can you say this line and
do the face
and
he's like yeah [ __ ] it
you're paying me the same stable jesus
said the biggest problem we had in the
revolutionary war is we didn't have
enough airports
sorry what
whoa
[Laughter]
what
what
excuse me
excuse me jill biden's husband
he's like wait a minute wait a hold on a
second here who wrote this script the
same stable jesus said the biggest
problem we had in the revolutionary war
the same stable jesus said that in the
biggest problem
okay now i believe that joe biden
husband before i
i wasn't a believer in the conspiracy
but now i see
i mean maybe he said that who knows can
we fact check this hello oh my gosh okay
you go go in and tell yeah somebody
should go in and tell somebody my new
favorite tik tok right here
it's so good
the urge and seeing the voice it's funny
for a second and then they're like wait
a minute she could actually die we need
to tell her okay so you go go in and
tell them yeah it do looks very clean
though maybe we're the ones doing it
wrong that's the car they said huh
what's the problem this has the same
energy of people trying to put gas in
the teslas but i think this one prompts
it honestly
you can do it all right like it makes
sense in climbing it and then it makes
sense i'm going across it but like how
did he get like that
man
we've all been there trying to do
pull-ups and you get stuck just give him
time man well i said
it's a caught mid in a weird movie or
some [ __ ]
okay this isn't funny i just thought it
was kind of cool
is it impossible to stop mid swing i
never tried it
it just makes it look so clean like nah
not feeling it
[Music]
how does he know
what was wrong with that that looked
good what's so special i did is in wii
sport golf all the time or confuse
people stopping a club in swing isn't
hard physically it's not heavy but in
competition on live tv you quickly
decided to not yeah i don't think it's
that hard but he makes it look clean
excuse me
yes
uh when when's the uh essay gonna be due
by
i think we're gonna have that due
towards the end of next week
okay um and
how did you hear me say that
um i i can but you're not supposed to
know that what
bruh that is a brah moment that can't be
real
there's no way no
that's evil that's too evil but teachers
are evil hmm
can't tell if real surely a teacher
wouldn't put up in a tick-tock sketch i
mean i understand how he would do it but
why would she sing
hmm
i don't know is it real
[Music]
hell yeah
that's how it's done baby
[Laughter]
let's go
planet fitness baby that's how we doing
hey ready
resurrection great for your core
google released a new fast eye mirror
oh my gosh dude i had a dream about this
what the
[ __ ] no you look beautiful and then you
just start having a conversation just
like you would if you were physically
like a 3d image
this is wild i can see that curl in your
hair i can see how your sweater is
falling i'm inside then you'll be saying
put on a little lipstick
there are really three breakthroughs
coming together here one is what is i
gotta google it what this is what this
is
project starlight cause last tick tock i
found one where they uh that they
scrapped uh the google assistant making
calls for you and apparently they
scrapped that project which is the
biggest letdown of my entire life
uh but what it what what it do but you
both have to have it right
this is so sci-fi like in movies
so you look beautiful and then you just
start having a conversation just like
you would if you were physically
together there are really three
breakthroughs coming together here one
is the ability to capture people as they
are
the second is the ability to compress
that information and send it over
existing networks efficiently and the
third is the ability to render that
person viewable through a
three-dimensional display so it really
feels like you're talking with
i gotta i gotta know if it actually
really feels right i mean you can kind
of tell already from this footage that
something's off but that's pretty cool
i kind of want it i want it now so you
need this thing in front of you it's not
uh all right cool okay okay okay okay
this is the greatest tick tock i take
back what i said
this is my favorite the thing with tick
tock is that sometimes people just post
whatever and they unintentionally become
popular because it's so funny
even though they're not funny
it literally went into their yard
literally
[Laughter]
stop
stop it
stop it did not
it's literally
literally where they are
my face gross
i feel like i'm the only one who thinks
this is funny
they literally went into their yard
stop stop stop
i'm [ __ ] dying dude it literally
stop
stop your foot you're crazy anna anna
you're so insane at least
blessed
i may have found something that proves
that the government makes humans hey
every boy duet this and cfo i think i
heard about this right on your arm
is that a freckle that's a mole no okay
they all have it no [ __ ] way dude
that guy's funny
you should make a tick tock no
well well well thank you for watching
another tech talk epic subscribe epic
like epic smash subscribe again just for
good luck and good fortune for the rest
of the week see you tomorrow
[Music]
and you can't go to the zoo need to go
to the [ __ ] loop i got
something something for you
and you leave to the river
like a puppy in the pot fishing
something without shame second part of
my great shame are you feeling
in the mood for creation my dear legolas
nation and for the dedication explore
fart and mushroom poop pad castle melon
goblin book even ones that i can't see
just downloaded for free
[Music]
i got something for you
[Music]
[Applause]
you